Transcriber: Oyku 25
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Merhaba hoşgeldiniz.
Öncelikle gerçekten çok heyecanlıyım.
Böyle dilim sürçerse lütfen kusura
bakmayın. Başını da birazcık ezberleyerek
gideceğim konuşmanın.
Çok güzel bir sahne.
Gerçekten yıllarca hayalini kurduğum
bir sahne burası.
Daha öncesinde sizin oturduğunuz yerde
Tedx konuşmalarını izlerken hep
hayal ediyordum.
Acaba günün birinde
gerçekten ben de
bu sahneye çıkabilecek miyim diye.
Ve çıktım. Şu an buradayım.
Şöyle bir derin nefes alacağım
ve başlayacağım artık.
Biliyorsunuz.
Tedx’in bu yılki teması Before-After.
Before-After diyince merak ediyorum
aslında diyetisyenler ile bağdaştıran
ve diyetisyen deyince
akla Before-After gelen var mı ?
Ellerini kaldırabilir mi acaba?
Genelde öncesi ve sonrası diye fotoğraf
paylaşırlar bizim meslekte. Tahmin ettiğim
gibi ne yazık ki bağdaştırılıyoruz.
Ben çok hoşlanmıyorum açıkçası
bu durumdan.
Şimdi ben birazcık hayatımın şu before
kısmından bahsetmek istiyorum.
Ben diyetisyen Private Chef Buket Çürük,
ben nasıl bir diyetisyen oldum, nasıl bir
private chef oldum ve bu noktaya gelirken
bu iki mesleği nasıl bir araya getirdim?
Nasıl meşakkatli yollardan geçtim?
Bunları anlatmak istiyorum size.
Aslında
Adana’nın küçük bir ilçesinde
doğdum,büyüdüm.
Annem hemşire, babam esnaf.
Bilirsiniz sağlık çalışanlarının
hayatları oldukça yoğundur ve
başkalarının hayatlarını kurtarırken
aslında kendi hayatlarında birçok
şeyi ıskalarlar.
Bizde de aslında durum
tam olarak böyleydi.
Bizim evimizde yardımcı bir ablamız vardı
ve annemin nöbette olduğu, babamın yoğun
çalıştığı dönemlerde biz o
ablamız da öyle mükellef
bir abur cubur sofrası hazırladık
ki ben bayılıyordum o duruma.
Hala gözümün önünde ve hala
yalan söylemeyeceğim.
Çok seviyorum o anları.
Tabii bu keyifli fakat sağlıksız beslenme
stili benim çocukluğum ve ergenlik
döneminin kilo problemi ile
savaşmama neden oldu.
Sonuç dediğim gibi 120 kilo bir buket.
Üniversite hazırlık dönemlerine geldik.
Tercih yapacağım.
120 kiloyum.
Karar verdim.
Ben kesinlikle diyetisyen olacağım.
Tercih yaptık.
Haliç Üniversitesi 2010 2012.
Pardon Haliç Üniversitesi Beslenme
ve Diyetetik kazandım.
Azmettim, diyorum ki
ben kesinlikle
diyetisyen olacağım.
Bu kilo vereceğim, mezun olacağım,
şahane bir diyetisyen olacağım.
Üniversite bitti, ben hala 120 kiloyum.
Babam orada izliyor.
Bana vaad ettiği şeyleri bilseniz ben o
kilo vermem için neler veriyor bana.
Ama yok.
Ben de tık yok.
Ben yemeyi seviyorum.
Devam.
Eh tabii üniversiteyi bitirdik.
120 kiloyuz.
Biliyorsunuz Türkiye şartlarında 120 kilo
50 beden bir diyetisyen olmak
çok da mantıklı bir şey değil.
Üniversite bitirmenin sevincini
bile yaşamadım.
Çünkü işsizim.
Özgüvenim sıfır.
Gerçekten motivasyonum sıfır.
Mental sağlığım sıfır, yerlerde.
Benim bir şeyler yapmam lazım.
Çünkü bir diyetisyenliği
yapamayacağım belli.
Kilo da veremiyorum.
Hayatımda en çok tutkulu olduğum
şeyi merak ettim.
Ben kesinlikle mutfağa çok seviyorum.
Mutfakta olmaktan inanılmaz mutluyum.
Bütün günümü geçirsem bıkmam.
O zaman dedim ki ben kesinlikle
aşçılık okuyacağım.
Mutfak sanatına, Akademisi'ne, anne ve
babamdan gizli mülakata girdim, kazandım.
Sonra anneme söyledim.
Annem zaten her zaman destekçi bana babam
birazcık orada mırın kırın etti
“Sen diyetisyen
nasıl aşçılık istersin?” diye.
Ama azmettim.
Ben aşçılığı okudum.
Sekiz aylık bir zorlu bir eğitim süreci.
Oldukça zorluydu gerçekten
ama hayatımın en güzel dönemleriydi.
Mutfağı inanılmaz seviyordum,
söylemiştim zaten.
Sonrasında bu eğitimimin
bitmesi sonucunda bir staj dönemi oluyor
ve ben orada o
kadar şanslıyım ki, tam da istediğim gibi
bir ekibe, tam da istediğim bir mutfak
olan İtalyan mutfağına girdim.
Danilo zamanın ekibinde yer aldım.
Gerçekten o yaptığım staj benim yerlerde
olan öz güvenimi inanılmaz etkiledi.
Bir kıpırdanmalar oldu.
Ben kendime güvenmeye başladım.
Onun sonucunda karar verdim.
Ailemin de desteğini aldım.
Babamın desteğini aldım.
Ve ben Adana'ya dönüp kendi işimi
yapmaya karar verdim.
Kendi işimi yapacağım, kendi danışmanlık
ofisini açacağım ve insanlara gerçekten
kiloyla ilgili problemlerinde
çözüm bulacağım.
Çünkü onların ne yaşadığını gerçekten
çok iyi hissediyorum.
Şimdi burada birazcık şu bir fuar
kısmına es vermek istiyorum.
Hayatımın şu dönemi bence benim after
kısmı olan yani sonrası kısmına gerçekten
çok büyük öncü olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Ofisim açtım, 4 sene geçti.
Gerçekten inanılmaz insanlarla tanıştım,
inanılmaz danışmanlıklar verdim.
Çok güzel ilerliyoruz ama bir
şeyler eksik gidiyor.
Tabii o dönemde yeni tanıştığım,
şu an eşim olan en büyük
destekçilerimden biri,
Can’la tanıştık ve
Can’la sürekli düşünüyoruz.
Ya bizim yeni bir şey yapmamız lazım.
Yani farklılık yaratmamız lazım, insanlar
bu diyeti yaparken zorlanıyor.
Yemek yemeyi seven bir toplumuz,
Adanalıyız.
Ne yapacağız? O zaman
bizim bu işin içine kesinlikle mutfağı bir
an önce açıp dahil etmemiz gerekiyor.
Düşünüyoruz.
İnanın mutfak açmak hiç o kadar
kolay bir şey değilmiş.
Bunu hep en başından ben istiyordum
ama şu an diyorum ki
iyi ki tam zamanında olması gerektiği
bir zamanda açılmış.
Çünkü çok meşakkatli bir yol,
çok zor bir yol.
Biz Kasım 2021′de mutfağımızı açtık.
Açtık ama benim asistanım yoktu o dönem.
Ben gündüz hem danışan bakıyorum.
Akşam saat 3 gibi çıkıyoruz.
Eşim beni alıyor, mutfağa geçiyoruz.
Bir yandan böyle ben yemekleri yapıyorum.
Eşim dağıtıma çıkıyor.
Danışanlarıma da şey diyorum,
benim hayali bir
asistanım vardı telefonda.
Ama söylemiyorum asistanım
olmadığını da işte diyorum
“Sizinle ilgilenecek asistanımız
yazacak merak etmeyin.”
Bütün her şeye hani ben döndüğüm için
sıkıntı yaşıyoruz zaten.
Hatta danışanların en
büyük şikayeti de o dönem
şeydi: “Buket Hanım size ulaşamıyoruz.”
Buket Hanım çünkü sürekli bir
koşturmaca halinde
hayalinin peşinden gitmeye çalışıyor.
İyi ki o yolları geçmişim diyorum.
Gerçekten çok mutluyum o noktada.
Sonrasında baktığınızda biz
2021 Kasım ayında
Chef’s Kitchen markasını kurduk
dediğim gibi.
Gerçekten Adana’nın bence tek
private hizmet veren kişiye özel beslenme
programı oluşturan bir mutfak
oldu ve çok güzel ilerledi.
Genelde danışmanların şu sözü söylüyordu
bana: “Ya Buket Hanım,
siz bunun diyet yemeği olduğuna
emin misiniz bunlar aşırı lezzetli?”
yani sürekli bu tepki geliyor ve inanın
yaptığım tek şey
yemeği aşırı severek yapmam.
Beni hiçbir şekilde zorlamıyor.
Danışmanlığı da seviyorum ama mutfak
ayrı bir sevgi veriyor bana.
Sonrasında şu an bulunduğumuz
konuma geldik aslında.
Şimdi orada birazcık yavaşlamamı
isteyecekler.
Ben zaten hızlı konuşacağım
diye düşünüyordum.
Tahminim yine hızlı konuştum.
Heyecanlıyım dediğim gibi kusura bakmayın.
Mutfağımız oldu.
Güzel gidiyor her şey.
Ama yine bir eksiklik var.
Bir şeyler katmamız gerekiyor.
O zaman farklı paketler olsun, farklı
içerikler olsun ve
insanların motivasyonu
kuvvetlendirecek şeyler olsun istedik.
Bunların hepsine aşama aşama ilerledik.
Ben şuna gerçekten canı
gönülden inanıyorum.
Bir şey istiyorsanız bu
bir şekilde oluyor.
Ne zaman oluyor bunu bilemiyorum.
Benim her zaman geç oldu.
Ne zaman neyi istesem hep bir geç oldu.
Hatta minik bir anından da
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Mutfak hayalim benim hep üniversiteyi
bitirdikten sonra,
ofisim açtıktan sonra
hemen olmasını istediğim bir şeydi.
Ama 5 yıl sonra oldu.
Bir gün eşim eve geldi.
Ben hüngür hüngür ağlıyorum.
Biraz da utanıyor bunu anlatırken ama
başka meslektaşlarım, mutfak sevmeyen,
çok alakası olmayan insanlar, çoktan
mutfak açmışlar.
Ben hüngür hüngür ağlıyorum.
Ya diyorum
onlar açtı, ben hala açamadım.
Ben hala bu tutkumla bu mutfağı açamadım.
Eşim bana ″sabret Buket″ demişti.
Her şeyin zamanı var.
Gerçekten diyorum.
Şu iyi ki şu zamanda Kasım'da açmışız.
Dönüşler şahane.
Her şey çok güzel.
Benim öyle çok büyük.
Hani size verebileceğim başarılarım yok.
Henüz daha 27 yaşındayım.
Bilmiyorum Suna Kıraç’ın kitabını
okudunuz mu?
“Ömrümden uzun ideallerim var”
diye bir kitabı var.
Ben o kitabı çok seviyorum.
O kitabın ismini çok seviyorum.
Gerçekten ömründen uzun ideallerim var
ve başarmak istediğim, daha çok şey var.
En büyük hedeflerimden birisi de zaten
mutfakla ilgili sürecin artık tamamlanması
daha da ileriye gitmesi.
Bu noktada şunu da
söylemek istiyorum aslında
İnsan kırılma noktasını yaşarsa,
bir şekilde hepimizin hayatında bir
kırılma noktası olmuştur.
Üzüldüğünüz, canınızın sıkıldığı
Bunu kilo konusunda da söyleyebiliriz.
Ben danışmanlarına genellikle sorarım
“Niye kilo vermek istiyorsunuz
sizi buraya ne getirdi?”
Bu işte bir kırılma noktasıdır aslında.
Umarım hepimiz o kırılma noktasını bir
an önce yaşarsınız ve umarım konfor
alanını hepimiz dışına çıkar ve
gelişmek için çaba sarf ederiz.
Çünkü insan ancak o zaman
hakikaten zorlandığında
bir şeylere başarı elde edebiliyor.
Tıpkı bu TEDx sahnesinde olmak gibi.
Bu gerçekten büyük bir hayaldi.
Yalan söylemeyeceğim.
Bütün gece boyunca çalıştım.
Ama dedim ki Buket kendin gibi ol.
Zaten bence o duyguyu da
hissettireceksin dedim.
Herhalde hissettiriyorum
diye düşünüyorum.
Teşekkür ederim.
Şimdi birazcık konuşmamı böyle
yavaş yavaş bitireceğim.
Konuşmamın sonunda da açıkçası 3 tane
görsel hazırlamıştım.
Dedim ki ben onlara da bakmayacağım
her şeyi karıştırıyorum çünkü.
Konuşmamın sonunda şans eseri önüme
çıkan Pink Floyd’un bir tane sözü vardı,
bunu da bir TEDx konuşmasında görmüştüm.
Çok hoşuma gitti sizinle
Paylaşmak istedim.
“Her birinize hayallerinde kendi yarattığı
duvarları samimiyetle, özenle, sabırla,
yıkmanızı diliyorum.”
Beni dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür ediyorum.